so we're in brazil last week part of the
time in rio so naturally we hooked up
with glenn greenwald who lives there
went over to his house had a bunch of
interesting conversations one of them's
on tape here's part of it
so in american media you often hear
bolsonaro dismissed as a dictator now
whatever you think of his policies if he
were a dictator he would have the two
things that all dictators have
a a cult of personality and be a
compliant media to reinforce that cult
of personality and as it turns out
bolster doesn't have either one of those
things in fact brazil does not have a
significant media that challenges the
establishment narrative
and we asked paul cerro
why that is and what would happen if
something like i don't know fox news
existed in brazil here's what he said
why is there no fox news in brazil cnn
is here you got over 50 million votes in
the last election cnn's a political
player here so it was globo but there's
no
tv channel for your voters
well if i could you know launch an
appeal to you i can only say that you
will be the most welcome in brazil you
will be an excellent counterpart to the
other vehicles or outlets
there are very few media outlets that
are really unbiased in brazil
that's something we need
and we do have one program in the
javanpan network called the dots in the
eyes the dots in the eyes or the dots on
the eyes and they're excellent they
really showcase the good things going on
in this country
flattering will admit that not speaking
portuguese could be a hurdle in the
largest portuguese speaking country in
the world
but to the question of free speech which
really is the acid test do you have free
speech or don't you it's a really simple
test you have free speech when you can
say something that most people consider
offensive or outrageous of you that is
held by very few people
and not be punished for saying it that's
what free speech is
does brazil have free speech well
earlier this year perhaps the most
popular podcaster in the country a guy
known as monarch
played out a thought experiment on his
show in which he said you know even
extremist parties should be recognized
by law in brazil not that i'm for them
but you should be allowed to have any
political party you want because that's
what freedom is
in response to saying this the attorney
general brazil opened an investigation
into monarch he was fired and kicked off
of youtube glenn greenwald saw this
happen in real time he knows brazil well
he's lived here for 17 years he's an
independent journalist with an emphasis
in independent and he joins us tonight
with his assessment glenn thanks so much
for coming on so
i was really struck there's so much
about brazil that's
amazing and impressive and i understand
why you moved here
but the question of free speech media
freedom how does that stand would you
say now in brazil yeah you know i think
one of the benefits of living in a
foreign country for a while is that you
see some of the flaws of your country
but you also see a lot of the
really good sides and one of the things
that exists in the united states that
doesn't exist in a lot of other
countries including brazil
is a more pluralistic media than is
available in a lot of other places even
if it's just fox news and other
right-wing outlets some places as you
just said have none here in brazil the
country has been notoriously dominated
by four or five industrialized families
who control almost all media and their
overarching ideology really is neither
right nor left but preservation of
establishment power and ruling class
orthodoxy and they've had a block on
mainstream discourse for so long the
question of free speech as well
when
monarch that
podcast host that you just referenced
said
i think the government shouldn't have
the power to ban certain political
parties to me that is completely
uncontroversial that's the state of the
law in the united states because of our
constitution and when i defended him one
of the very few people who did
i was treated like a leper you know
people saying this freedom of speech is
a fascist ideology and we don't want it
here
which is so ironic given that the
hallmark of actual fascists is
censorship not free inquiry and free
discord
and it's even more ironic given that a
lot of people on the left who don't
believe in free speech here seem to
trust either the government currently
run by president bolsonaro or american
billionaires who control big tech who
they seem to be comfortable controlling
their political discourse what's
interest and i should say just because i
don't think our audience knows you did
more than complain about the censorship
of this podcast you helped him
get a new job so bless you for that
um
but the question of american media is
important here because bolsonaro no
matter what you think of him relies
pretty much exclusively on
american-owned tech platforms twitter
specifically to get his message out
doesn't that make him
totally vulnerable to censorship by
american companies well he has been
repeatedly censored by big tech
platforms he when speaking about kobit
was often censored when speaking about
the upcoming election is often censored
so facebook and google are essentially
dictating to brazilians what they can
and can't hear including from their own
democratically elected president and
again no matter what you think of
bolsonaro you should have to think that
that's a pretty
serious problem and i think it's a very
similar dynamic to what has happened in
the u.s where
the entire establishment essentially
united against trump and so all these
institutions that liberals on the left
in the united states have long held with
such contempt neocons and the security
state and corporate media all united
against trump and suddenly they were
viewed with such favor by the american
left and by american liberalism that has
happened to a large extent here a
brazilian leftist will now often talk
about globo along the long uh worst
enemy of the brazilian left with a lot
of gratitude operation yeah it's the
major media company that has become
completely hostile to bolsonaro because
again bolsonaro
ran on a platform of anti-establishment
uh challenge and defiance and that's not
what has been his government is but just
the rhetoric itself has made the
establishment turn against him amazing
amazing the parallels here in brazil i
just recommend to everyone come and
spend a week here it's just it's a
remarkable reflection of our own society
glenn greenwald thank you great to be
with you great to see you
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight